our parent company next star teaming up
with feeding america to fight hunger
this month and three square of course is
a member and christian casares showing
us how the organization works with
schools to make sure no child goes
hungry
happiness you know it just we got food
and that's the main one you can see 18
year old yasmin lopez smile even behind
her mask
because she knows today food at home is
secured thanks to the efforts of the
clark county school district and
community partners we get help at school
we get our food winners
they give us a bag of food currently a
hundred sites around the valley offer
food to students from a usda waiver
which allows breakfast and lunch free of
charge according to ccsd dietitian
christina syed when creating the
breakfast and lunch menus we must ensure
that we are following the usda meal
pattern
syeb says kids ages 2 to 18 are eligible
regardless if they are ccsd students or
not there are over 100 sites for food
pickup an essential service since one in
every three children in the valley
experience food insecurities according
to three square that doesn't necessarily
mean the child is going hungry because
we know that oftentimes parents will
actually prioritize food for their kids
over food for themselves but it means
that children are at particular risk
about a million pounds of food is
delivered daily to ccsd's food services
facility near the speedway here the food
is produced and sealed for the majority
of elementary schools secondary schools
order the food and bulks and prep it on
site for those who need it like lopez
they give us the
turkey for thanksgiving as well so we
had our full meal christian casarez 8
news now
besides distributing food three square
does need some donations the four
corners food drive radiothon underway
runs right through friday and you can
help out and donate on threesquared.org
every dollar donated provides for those
kids three meals it's very important if
you can and there's so many kind-hearted
people in las vegas so i know those
donations will come in oh they certainly
will the money goes a long way